you know i i thought about it you know
whenever they gave us an option i i
really
i thought about all of my options i
thought i'm on my family and i thought
about
you know i took um you know serious
consideration and the things that
you know could possibly happen you know
but for me i think the broncos are doing
a great job
you know keeping us safe and as always
hoes there's always going to be hopes
we're not in a
like a total like bubble it's not 100
percent like basketball so they're
always going to be hoes but i feel like
the job that the broncos were doing to
keep us safe were enough for me
you know not to opt out and um you know
i just think you know
uh last year i didn't play to i didn't
play to
you know sauce money done in standards i
didn't i didn't play to
the sac master standards i i feel like
it was more for me to give
my coaches felt like it was more for me
to give and um you know most of all i
feel like i could
you know i could give more i feel like i
can be more and you know i don't feel
like i'm feeling [ __ ] and
i don't want to come back here and i
want to play the best of the best that i
possibly could
i wanted to um put everything into the
off season i want to pour everything
into myself and go out there and play
the best i possibly could and
you know see what happens
von miller super bowl 50 mvp talking
yesterday about
his decision to not opt out chris he was
covet 19 positive in the offseason had
some symptoms
has some other health issues i think
asthma
is one of the things right yes
and and and you can i can't help but
wonder if he hadn't already had it
would he have been more likely to opt
out even though having it as we're
learning is not a golden ticket that
insulates you from getting it again
if you hadn't been through it and you
didn't know what it was going to do to
you i think maybe he's got some
confidence that if it would
happen again that it would be the same
and who knows who
who knows anything about this oh yeah i
know somebody i assume knows something
but that's why we were talking
with your own health well yeah that's
why we were talking about even with the
stafford family and so it's good to hear
people talk about it because i think
everybody lives in fear of like
we only hear the horror stories more
times than not so
to hear guys like von miller and you
know i know like ezekiel elliott he was
pushing it back about it by because he
wanted his privacy and things like that
but
you know to me as as players who are in
the spotlight you know share this
information
ease the pain and worries of some of
these people out there who are
you know kind of scared to death and
rightly so i understand of the virus
but i think it would go a long way to
the society when people hear guys like
von miller who i think is about a
stand-up
and one of my favorite players in
football my little girl charlotte's
favorite player
you know because he's got all these
chickens right so she loves him
that is my little girl's favorite player
in football but i'm glad to see von
miller out
and mike the other thing i love to uh or
out to play i should say the other thing
i love about von miller
like he addresses his play at the end of
that comment there
and brings it up himself you know i love
how he kind of puts himself out there
on a yearly basis he talked about his
play wasn't
up to his you know expectations last
year and everything he addresses it
you know like a man's man like a leader
of a football team like a
like a great all-time great that's what
they should do and
i i like that that aspect about von
miller and his personality
you know you made a comment earlier
about all we hear is horror stories the
reality is we've got over 150
000 horses country and it keeps going up
by more than a thousand a day so
it's it's hard to look past
the worst case scenarios because the
worst case scenario isn't theoretical
the worst case scenario is playing out
over and over
i didn't mean to sound insensitive i i
know i don't know no i
i i hear what you're saying that we it
one of the problems is we only have so
much capacity to process
right it is useful to hear the tale of a
guy who's been through it
who who understands what it is who can
advise teammates and others with
far more authority than someone who
hasn't had it and you know
you you'll wonder what kind of a
confidant
advisor von miller has been to some of
his teammates who have concerns who
maybe were thinking about
opting out and didn't and maybe some who
did like jawan james broncos right
tackle he decided to opt out and i think
everybody's got to make their own
decision
but you know von miller very transparent
the fact that he thought about it for
anybody else who's thinking about it you
have until 4 p.m eastern
on thursday that is the deadline that is
it now there are opportunities for
change circumstances if you
are diagnosed with one of the high risk
health conditions that you don't
currently have if that happens
later in the season you have a window to
opt out then if you have a family member
who dies or is hospitalized with covet
19
you have a window to opt out then
limited windows to opt out beyond
now and chris i'm going to bring back
the point that i made yesterday because
there was something von miller said that
made me think of it oh
he talked about how he came in and he
was able to get some confidence in
what's going on in the building
yeah that's fine but circumstances will
change
once you start practicing in pads
sweating and breathing and spitting and
bleeding on each other
once you start playing in games going to
kansas city
going here going there traveling being
in hotels that aren't part of the hotels
that you may be
comfortable staying in in your home
market you may feel differently then
that's the one factor and i guarantee
you with the sheer number of players in
the nfl we're going to hear
quotes from players who said i was fine
when we were just at camp but now that
we're taking this show on the road
and actually playing against these guys
who i don't know
and i don't know how how conscientious
they're being i know how conscientious
my team's being i don't know how
conscientious they're being i don't know
who's out there that may have the virus
that's when circumstances potentially
change and i wish there was some
mechanism
some slim window to give guys a chance
after the padded practices start after
the game start
to say now i really get to feel
what it's like and i'm choosing to not
do this yeah i mean
it's a tough conversation it's deep i
don't know if this segment
we got enough time here to get into all
of that but i mean you're right it
you know you'd like to have that type of
option is it realistic
i don't know you know that's that's the
real problem and what i would just say
to any
yeah don't tell jack del rio about that
oh i i know i heard he tried to give it
the old car comparison except you know
car crashes aren't contagious so i don't
know how that even
works there but either way you know when
i when i hear that
you know as far as the players need to
start wrapping their head around
it right now you know they got to and
they need to really think about it here
over the next 24 hours
because where it's not realistic too is
just you know again the team building
process you're putting the team in a bad
spot and i don't mean
sitting here want to sound insensive you
know i'm pro-player there but
you know i'm also look at it
realistically from a coach's standpoint
a front office standpoint
organization standpoint to go wow you
know
you might not be able to play the season
forget the virus if that's the case you
might
one team could have ten guys drop out
after week one or week two or their
first travel game like that and all of a
sudden
you know you have a team that can't even
feel the team
properly for the next week or whatever
may be so
there's just a lot of moving parts there
i hear you i just don't know if it's
realistic
and i i admire what the nflpa did to buy
some extra time for the players one
thing jc trader mentioned to me
yesterday
yeah that was cool about this he pointed
out he pointed out
look this extra time allowed guys as
part of their preliminary physicals at
the start of camp to make sure the
record's clear
on what health conditions they have and
don't have because
some guys are going to be leery they
don't want to say well you know what i
have diabetes because they don't want
that to be held against them when it's
time to decide who's on the team and
who's not
now is the time to get it in writing now
is the time to make sure
that they know what you have if you're
thinking about opting out because
there's a big difference
between opting out with a risk factor
and just opting out because you're not
comfortable
if you just do a general opt out with no
risk categorization
it's a one hundred fifty thousand dollar
stipend that will be repaid
either from future salary or out of your
own pocket if you have one of the risk
factors and you fall into one of those
categories and it's properly documented
you get 350 000 this year that never
gets paid back that never gets withheld
from your salary in the future
so it is a huge difference and this time
that
elapsed between july 24 and monday
august 3
bought the players several more days of
making sure that they got
everything in writing as to what they do
and don't have
but still still i wish
that the players had
a little more flexibility yeah maybe a
lot more flexibility i'm trying to put
myself in the shoes chris of somebody
who's got to make a decision right now
yeah between now and and 4 p.m eastern
tomorrow what i'm doing for the next
five or six months
am i walking away or am i going to do
this
knowing that i can't change my mind and
let me reiterate this and i need to
write about this again at pft
for the guys who are trying to make this
decision talk to your agent
look at your contract look at what your
repayment obligation for signing bonus
money would be
if you do this you can still retire
and then unretire retirement isn't
permanent
all this crap we hear from time to time
about oh he filed his papers
none of that means anything you retire
you get put on the reserve retired list
how do you get off the reserve retired
list you send a letter to the
commissioner saying
i unretire you can leave and return
whenever you want
so if you're feeling stressed out about
this decision and if you're inclined to
go forward
but you're worried that maybe i'll feel
differently
once we start practicing maybe i'll feel
differently once we start playing games
talk to your agent talk to the union
talk to someone who understands how to
look at that contract and give you
advice
on what you would owe the team if you
retire there are plenty of guys
who could say you know what i'll go
forward knowing that i can retire
and then unretire re-retire and do that
as a way to manage this concern that i
have that
once we start playing games i may feel a
lot differently than i do today
yeah well yeah yeah i mean listen that's
an angle you can certainly take
uh i i would just think you know as a
player
that you've been thinking about this for
the last you know three months and
you're constantly every day okay i gotta
train for football wait are we gonna
have football am i gonna do this am i
gonna be comfortable where is this gonna
go
all those things are just going off a
checklist in your brain and
you know over the last few days we've
heard two star players talk about hey
we i've been thinking about it you know
odell beckham jr
you know whether you like it or not yeah
he admitted he wasn't sure if this
season should happen i don't know where
it's going to go
but he got in there now and he's seen
the protocols von miller has
pretty much echoed the same thing even
though he had coveted before that
and i i would just hope most players
have their head wrapped around what they
had signed up for by this time anyways
added to the fact like you said and jc
shredder said
you know they've had a good 10 days now
11 days
to see how this process is working and
evolving and everything like that
to hopefully that has made them more
comfortable in their decision to play
and
we'll see where it goes all i know is
i'm happy von miller's playing because
he's a stud and a superstar
right and it's a big year for him let me
just make this point we have to take a
break but
but here's the best technology that that
i can give you chris
i didn't know what it would feel i know
what it feels like to go to the grocery
store
i didn't know what it would feel like to
go to the grocery store in a pandemic
until i did it and then i could decide
after that whether or not i wanted to go
back to the grocery store
the one point that is missing from your
analysis is these guys don't know what
it's going to feel like to play
football i know in a pandemic until they
do
that's the flaw here that's the problem
here you can feel perfectly safe in your
cocoon
that is your practice facility you may
not feel that way after you're playing a
game and i
wish that the nfl would as just a
reflection of self-awareness
and appreciation of humanity be ready to
give these guys a chance to opt out if
they truly have concerns after playing
in a game that's all i'm saying hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports